just kidding don't know
actually who is behind of this
[Music]
life is not good
all the bodies that they find there was
tight
[Music]
in the wake of mozambique's worst attack
yet by militants who say they're linked
with isis
we've been given extraordinary access
into the town which was targeted
we're flown in by military helicopter
the only way into palma right now
in the remote northern cava delgado
province
at this point it's nearly two weeks on
from the violent attacks here
and there are still thousands of people
missing
on the ground soldiers and mozambique
and special forces are spread throughout
and the hunt is on for those who wrought
such terrible terror here
many of the residents are still only
just emerging after hiding in the bush
ever
since they're all very hungry they've
survived on root vegetables
and rain water up until now
the soldiers are wary of those trying to
re-enter the town
in case the extremists are hiding
amongst them posing as villages
only to mount another attack and they're
lined up to be questioned
and inspected before any of them are
allowed through the center of palma has
taken
a terrible battering
pump we're with the governor of the
province who's also seeing the
destruction for the first time
the dead are still laying in the open in
the street
they haven't been able to retrieve them
up until now
and there are modest attempts to give
some respect to those who died in this
terrifying and violent assault
we saw a body in what appeared to be
camouflage clothing
wearing an ammunition vest an outfit
favored by the terror group
known as al-shabab or isis mozambique
the attackers swept through palmer
setting fire to shops
homes and offices all the town's key
infrastructure was targeted
including the hospital and the
administrative offices
and the mobile phone network was
destroyed
how can you guarantee it won't happen
again at this i can't say
this i can't say what i have to say is
that
we we are we are here with our troops
and uh
we we feel we feel okay
we saw the first residents to trickle
back into the town after hiding for
nearly two weeks
grabbing what they could from the
vandalized shots
these are desperate times for palmer's
residents
the struggle to survive is not yet over
for those who managed to escape the
attackers
tensions are still incredibly high the
troops we were with arrested three young
men who they say were acting
that was a gunshot and we were
immediately hurried away and out of the
town
the military may have moved into palmer
but there are still multiple challenges
facing them
the attack has halted work on the 60
billion
liquefied natural gas project outside
palma on the afunji peninsula
this was meant to transform the fortunes
of this desperately poor region
now security's been stepped up the
project is vitally important for
mozambique's economy
but in the smaller fungi airport
terrified palmer families who've taken
refuge there
told us how they fled for their lives i
went to pick up my family
my wife and the kids all of them then we
went to the bush for the people there
was followers in the back
so after that when we jumped we jumped
one river
we found the people's with the gun they
were shootings one and one pips another
and there's
another people all just chipping at the
people so we tried to run away
they're killing people how
they shoot people even they're following
or shooting us
the governor went to try to reassure the
thousands of people who fled the
insurgents
and have now taken sanctuary in the
katunda resettlement village on the edge
of the lng site
this village was built for those
displaced by the huge gas project
but the numbers have now swelled to
bursting
we're hungry we're hungry they keep
telling us and with all unaided flights
halted because of the militant attacks
these people have had
very little to eat or drink in nearly a
fortnight
they're all saying how hungry they are
and making us
move and for the authorities to stop
this conflict
look at them they're all calling they're
all saying
food we want food
the governor promised they'd get help
and be able to return to palmer within
days
but they're getting more and more
desperate and more worryingly for
mozambique
is how it protects these people controls
this militant insurgency and stops it
from spreading
little is known about this shadowy group
which the us government has put on the
international terrorists because of its
apparent links with isis
it has no known leader and appears to
have foreign recruits from across the
border in tanzania along with ugandans
somalians even arabs among its fighters
and it appears well funded too with
plenty of weapons and ammunition
mozambique has abundant natural
resources
and its beautiful beaches are an
important attraction for its growing
tourist industry
but it's still ranked one of the poorest
countries in the world
with more than half its population
living below the poverty line
although before the emergence of this
militant group about four years ago
it had a history of religious tolerance
there are suspicions the insurgency has
more to do with geopolitical rivalries
linked to africa's single biggest
investment in mozambique
when we go back to palmer a few days
later were in a convoy of contractors
and selected journalists
palmer is the nearest town to the lng
project
and was considered secure the president
knows his forces were caught off guard
and is busy during our visit trying to
bolster international cooperation
which he will need if mozambique is to
defeat this terrorism
a lot more soldiers in palmer an
awful lot more people as they're trying
to encourage them to come back
and try to reassure them that they are
safe again
the residents are returning slowly
they're amongst the poorest in the
country
and there are worries that some may have
been seduced to join the armed group
through poverty and desperation
one contractor with us was aghast at
seeing the damage done to his business
you see what's happened that's outside
you see you think the truck is okay i
opened and everything's been
inside it's going to be tough to restore
confidence here
i finish with mozambique you know i'll
try to sell my company
i cannot stay you know i've got family i
need to take care of
them
there's an ongoing investigation into
not only how the militants managed to
overrun the town
but how they went on to lay siege to
this hotel
which was packed with nearly 200 people
amongst them
expats foreign workers and villagers
who'd taken refuge here
the amaroola lodge has been ransacked
now by looters
who seem to have gone into every room
turning it upside down
and stripping it of valuables survivors
told us
of a terrifying three days under fire
surrounded by militants and left to fend
for themselves
among them were these two south africans
wes on the left and his older brother
adrian
[Music]
this footage filmed by wes on his phone
shows them taking cover in the hotel
his brother is lying in front of his
father greg in the czech shirt
[Music]
now back home in johannesburg wes said
the shooting and mortar firing
was constant you know the gunfire
just didn't stop the mortars i mean
you're talking about hundreds of mortars
going off
like probably
40 50 in an hour
but despite the fighting getting closer
and closer the brothers are constantly
supporting each other
love you bro love you my man
at this stage only small helicopters
operated by the private security company
dag
appeared to be mounting any rescue
people were getting frantic
but dag had already airlifted more than
20 people from the amarilla
and promised to return we need
confirmation
asap using their satellite phones
those still trapped in the amarillo
repeatedly ask for help
wearing flak jackets left behind by aid
agencies
and with no weapons at all they come up
with a plan to break out of the lodge
side gate and retrieve a weapon they
think is in the parked car outside
they don't know how many insurgents are
lying in wait
but they know they're surrounded adrian
in the blue flak jacket
volunteers to do the running and
searching
what you're doing adrian come
adrian come it takes
three runs before they come back with a
single gun
with no help apparently coming they
began packing themselves into the
vehicles left at the lodge
the aim was to head out in a convoy
adrian would drive one car
it's gonna be the driver of your life
bro
within minutes they'd been ambushed
several drivers and vehicles were hit
and careered off the road the brother's
vehicle was amongst those who kept going
only to be ambushed a second time adrian
was shot twice
i was holding his shoulder over the
bullet went
trying to stop the blood and i was just
pumping out
ah started to drop and i was just
shouting back at them
to to put the other the other doses
inside the the bullet the the gunshot
wounds and um was he still talking
no he had stopped talking about that
time and i was just shouting
that i love him and that i look after
his family
and that i'm so sorry i'm so sorry that
this has happened to
they hid in the forest until the next
day before dag helicopters rescued them
with wares insisting they take his
brother's body with them
we did everything for everybody
and it felt like nobody was doing
anything for us
and my brother paid the ultimate price
they just abandoned us to help us
adrian leaves behind a wife and three
young children
and there was more under a tree opposite
the amarillo lodge the villagers told us
of a massacre they say they found a
dozen bodies which they buried here
all foreigners they thought taken from
the lodge
all of the bodies were laid out under
the tree
with the hands tied behind their backs
and heads had been cut off
mozambique's never seen anything like
this wanton brutality and violence
the insurgencies led to a mass
displacement of people
thousands of death and sparked an
humanitarian crisis
and the military admits they don't
really know what they're dealing with
we don't know the reason why they're
fighting or who the enemy is
so the hunters on to find out with
mozambique's leaders
under considerable pressure to stem this
insurgency
amid anxiety about what the terror group
may be planning next
alex crawford sky news in palmer
mozambique